estimated that net migration in the year
to June 2021
was at five sorry to June 2022 was at
504 000 pounds fat thousand this is
partly due to Temporary and exceptional
uh factors like the UK's Ukraine and
Hong Kong schemes last year over 200 000
ukrainians and 150 000 Hong Kong b o's
made use of the routes to life or time
in the United Kingdom these command
broad support from the British public we
were right to do so
the government introduced a point-based
system in 2020 to regain control of our
borders post brexit we are now need to
decide who comes to the UK and to
operate a system that conflicts to the
changing needs of the labor market such
as the skills needs of the NHS but
immigration is dynamic and we must adapt
to take account of changing behaviors
and if there is evidence of abuse
the number of dependents arriving
alongside International students has
risen more than eight-fold since 2019
from 16 000 in the year to December 2019
to 136
000 in the year ending December 2022
dependents of students make a more
limited contribution to the economy than
students or those coming under the
skilled worker root
but more fundamentally our system wasn't
designed for such large numbers of
people to come here in this manner
yesterday we introduced a package of
measures to help deliver our goal of
reducing net migration the package
includes removing the right for
international students to bring
dependents unless they're on Research
postgraduate courses and removing the
ability for international students to
switch out of the student route into
work routes before their Studies have
been completed
this is the right and fair thing to do
it ensures that we protect our public
services and housing Supply against
undue pressure and we deliver on the
promises that we've made to the public
to reduce net migration
our education institutions are world
renowned and for good reason and the
government remains committed to the
commitment in the International
Education strategy including the goal of
600 000 International students coming to
the United Kingdom each year
but
universities should be in the education
business not the immigration business
we're taking concerted action to deliver
a fair and effective immigration system
that benefits our citizens our
businesses and our economy we're
determined to get this right because
it's demonstrably in the National
interest
ing this urgent question must I thank
the minister for his response it's
disappointing that the Home Secretary is
not here herself or indeed that we have
to ask a urgent question rather than a
statement been made to the house
International students make an
invaluable contribution to our economy
according to the higher education policy
Institute last year and they provided
nearly 43 billion to the UK economy in
my constituency of Glasgow Northwest
alone the economic benefit was over 83
million so first of all I'd like to ask
the minister what assessments have been
carried out on the economic impact of
this change on the University sector and
indeed in University towns
International students enrich our
society and they have skills which are
proving ever more vital in this
post-brexit climate which has seen the
UK deprived of workers across key
sectors so with current labor shortages
in health care stem I.T to name but a
few how can the minister fail to
recognize that this policy will simply
exacerbate these
the reality is that many students coming
to the UK look beyond their studies and
want their families to be part of that
experience without a way for overseas
students to bring their families many
will opt to go elsewhere and any drop an
international student numbers will cause
further harm to universities that are
already facing financial difficulties
this policy makes the home secretaries
agenda Crystal Clear she's launching an
attack on migrants regardless of the
benefits they bring to the UK and in
pursuing the short-sighted reactionary
program International students have been
caught in the crossfire
in Scotland International students
contribution to University campuses and
to awaiter society is celebrated
but Scotland will suffer the
consequences of this misjudged policy
once again it's indicative of how out of
trend this conservative government is
with the Scottish people so if this
government is insistent in pursuing
their hostile environment will they now
accept that Scotland's needs and
Scotland's wants
are different to theirs
finally Mr Speaker
will the government now devolve
immigration powers to Scottish
Parliament to allow us to choose the way
that benefits our communities and our
society
well thank you Mr Speaker well no we
won't devolve immigration policy to the
Scottish government it's right that the
UK benefits from one immigration policy
and that's the way it will always
continue under this conservative
government but I'm afraid The Honorable
lady was misguided on a number of fronts
firstly of course it was this government
that created the International Education
strategy that was a strategy that set a
target of attracting 600 000
International students to the UK we've
met that Target 10 years early and we're
likely to exceed it this year the action
that we're taking today doesn't take
away from that goal it ensures that
there are no unintended consequences and
it was never the intention of that
policy to enable a very large number of
dependents to come to the UK with those
students it is right that universities
attract the best and the brightest and
that those who are on longer courses
such as phds or m-fills can bring
dependents with them but it's not right
that education is a back door for
immigration into the country
the statistics that I quoted earlier
show the very significant increases in
the number of student dependents in 2019
there were 16 000 visas issued to
student dependents last year that number
was 136
000 and eight and a half times increase
in 2019 for every 10 Indian students
there was one Visa issue to a dependent
last year that doubled to one in five
for Nigerian students studying in this
country in 2022 there were 65 000
dependent visas issued to only 59
000 students we don't want to do
anything that would harm the
international reputation of our
universities but it is right it is right
that we paid particular concern to
pressure on housing Supply to pressure
on public services
to integration and Community cohesion
and to making good on our commitment to
the British public that we will bring
down net migration which is what the
vast majority of the public want to see
done
Sir John Redwood when we invite people
to our country it's very important there
is good provision of Housing and school
places and health care and there are
huge stresses on the system
can the minister get the house some
guidance on how much the capital and
revenue setup cost is for a migrant
family coming in I think the EU and we
were in that some time ago reckoned it
was a quarter of a million euros for a
migrant coming into an advanced country
well it obviously varies very widely
between
the country of origin the skills of
those individuals and the points-based
system is set up in such a way to
encourage higher skilled individuals to
come to the UK for work purposes but he
is right to say that it is a relatively
accessible system and that has meant
very large numbers of people entering
the UK for a range of different reasons
in recent years and we should be acutely
concerned about the pressures that
that's having on housing Supply on
public services and on integration
particularly in those parts of the
country with very heated housing markets
such as the one that he represents and
that is why it is right that we take
action of the kind we are today
Stephen Kennett the shutter Minister
thank you very much Mr Speaker
International students are much valued
contributors to our world-class higher
education system which is a great asset
to our country but we and indeed
universities UK recognize that a tenfold
increase in the number of dependent
joining students in the UK since 2018
create significant challenges and that
enforcement measures are long overdue
and therefore the leader of the
opposition has has already made clear
and indeed our entire front bench that
we do not oppose these changes for
master students but as usual the
government has failed to deliver an
impact on these new rules and has left
many of the details very vague how many
people will this affect both in terms of
students and dependents what will the
actual impact be on the numbers the ons
defines an immigrant as someone who's
been here for more than a year or who's
coming for more than a year yet Masters
students are typically here for less
than a year but what is clear is that
dependents of students are only a
fraction of the story here in their 2019
Manifesto the conservatives acknowledge
that the brexit vote was a bid to Take
Back Control of immigration yet since
then net migration has sky rocketed from
226 000 to half a million which is at a
record high even if you exclude
ukrainians and Hong kongers and the
number of work visas has increased by 95
a staggering figure we're clear why this
has happened it's because for 13 years
the conservatives have failed to train
up Britain's homegrown talent to fill
the million vacancies we have and
because there are six million people on
NHS waiting lists in England alone most
of whom wish to return to the workforce
we want and expect net immigration to
reduce and we have set out plans for how
we'll get more of Britain's workers
trained up and back to work and today
the leader of the opposition has
announced that we will ditch the flawed
government policy which allows
businesses to undercut British workers
by paying migrant workers 20 Less in
sectors assigned to the shortage
occupation list so will the minister now
commit to scrapping the 20 wage discount
on the going rate for shortage
occupations nothing could be clearer the
conservatives have lost control of
immigration we on these benches are
committed to maximizing opportunities
for Britain's homegrown Talent
a minute well I'm I'm delighted to hear
that the honorable gentleman has had a
damascene conversion to tighter border
controls unfortunately I don't think the
British public will believe that it is
the same old labor party the party that
has always believed in open borders
their own leader campaigned for the
leadership
team
set to defend free movement only the
other day the chairwoman of the labor
party was saying that she expected
migration to rise under a future labor
government same flip-flopping approach
same open door policy we want to ensure
that we bring net migration down we
consider that to be a solemn promise to
the British public an important
Manifesto commitment this is a
significant policy which I'm glad to
hear The Honorable gentleman's support
which will make a tangible difference to
this issue it will reduce very
substantially the number of people
coming into the country as dependents
but there may be more that needs to be
done we're determined to tackle this
issue and ensure we bring that migration
down Greg Clarke thank you very much
indeed Mr Speaker the the minister is
doing a difficult job very well and he
set out the context and it's notable
that the front bench shares that
analysis uh but most students are
temporary visitors and yet they're
counted as many of them as permanent
immigrants so has my original friend
considered changing the definition to
include in the count only those who stay
[Music]
well I I respect my my rights I'm a
friend and his his deep knowledge of
this area I don't think it's helpful to
change the way in which the statistics
are reported uh I do think that it is uh
you have to consider the fact that
anyone coming into this country will
place pressure on our housing Supply on
public services in particular if they're
bringing dependents including young
children or elderly relatives into the
UK and in the present climate in which
there's significant pressure on public
services and significant pressure on
housing particularly in certain parts of
the country that is extremely important
we have seen historically that the vast
majority of students leave the country
and go back to their home country to
continue their careers and lives it's
too early to say whether the gradual
route will make a material difference to
that it may be that if individuals come
to the UK to study then spend a period
of time here on The Graduate route
certainly if they bring dependents that
we will start to see a significant
increase in the number of people staying
here making a life in the UK not
returning home in which case policies of
this kind will become more important
as some people spoke to personal
something of us thank you very much Mr
Speaker any
are celebrating all the international
students bring with the we are
international campaign the home office
is setting a bit undermining the UK's
place in the highly competitive
International Education Market I am
dismayed that the labor party are
supporting their measures today Canada
and Australia and the US must be rubbing
their hands in Glee Mr Speaker yet more
chopping and changing which makes the UK
less attractive research published by
happy last week shows that in 2020 122
the benefit to the UK for international
students stood at 41.9 billion with
every single constituency on these
islands seeing a benefit
and the dependents that come with them
often those husbands or wives are
working they're not a burden to the
state and they have to pay the
immigration Health surcharge as well
so can I ask the minister what is the
evidence for the policy that he's
brought forward today the written
statement yesterday speaks of issues
with agents and enhanced enforcement and
compliance so what detail does he have
to suggest that people are abusing is
already an incredibly expensive system
what equality impact assessment has he
carried out because universities UK
international have said that this that
restricting dependence will have a
disproportionate impact on women and
particular countries incidentally those
like Nigeria and India where the market
is growing and finally what discussions
has he had with the minister for hire
and further education in Scotland ahead
of this announcement and what impact
assessment has he carried out and how it
will affect institutions in Scotland
yeah yeah well we did think very
carefully about this measure and had
detailed conversations with colleagues
across government including of course
with the department for education and
indeed with with universities in in my
experience leaders of universities
understand the issue that we're
grappling with here they can see for
themselves the very significant increase
in the number of dependents who have
come to the UK in recent years and why
the government would feel the need to
take action the measures that we're
putting in place today will ensure that
there will still be a route for
dependents to come to the UK for
research courses such as phds where
people will be here for a sustained
period of time but there won't be for
those people here for short courses and
to give the honorable lady an example
last year there were 315
000 foreign Masters students in the UK
these are very large numbers of
individuals and if those people were to
bring dependents at scale that does put
pressure on public services and on
housing in the UK and I'm surprised that
the honorable lady doesn't appreciate
that particularly given the stages on
public services in Scotland
thank you uh Mr Speaker it's obviously
right that when we see see emerging
Trends in the immigration system that
cause concern that action is taken I
would though say if we're discuss things
like net migration we also need to be
clear about factors that contribute like
for example British citizens returning
to the UK and potentially bringing
children with them that also counts
towards net migration statistics but
clearly isn't something related to
immigration uh policy in terms of the
wider system though the rationale behind
this move I suspect the minister might
have wanted to announce something
slightly more comprehensive today rather
than just a focus on student dependence
and would he agree that actually it's
also about making sure we'd have the
immigration system having the
appropriate impact on the labor market
and looking more widely at things like
for example the salary thresholds we
have throughout the system as well as
just this change announced today
well I do think the package of measures
that we have announced will make a
tangible difference to net migration and
taken together with the easing of
exceptional factors like those Hong Kong
bno individuals coming to the UK over
the next year or two there is good
reason to believe that net migration
will fall and that we will be a better
place to meet our important Manifesto
commitment but he's right to say that it
is critical that we do so if there are
further measures that we consider them
uh and that we have to think carefully
about how migration interacts with the
British labor market because it is quite
wrong to perpetuate an economic model
that is overly reliant on foreign labor
and where people are coming here taking
jobs from British workers and we are not
tackling the core issue which is the
number of economically inactive people
in our country
thank you Mr Speaker Higher Education
Institute operate in a global market
which is why universities like Lancaster
University attract students from over
100 different countries many of whom
come study and then return now the
minister has raised the issue of
pressure on public services which makes
me wonder who he thinks has been in
charge for the past 13 years but my
question to the minister is what
consultations he had with universities
like Lancaster about the implications
for them on things like the global and
league tables for universities
well we have given careful thought to
this announcement I said earlier and
work closely with the department for
Education who of course had a bridge to
universities it's important to stress
that we have met the government's Target
of 600 000 International students 10
years early and are likely to exceed
that this year so there's no suggestion
that the number of international
students is going to diminish rapidly
what we're doing is tackling a
particular issue which is an unintended
consequence of earlier liberalizations
which is the very significant increase
in the number of dependents following
International students I would also say
that it is not healthy for British
universities to become overly reliant on
International students
just a few years ago only five percent
of the income of British universities
came from International students today
it's 18 and growing there's obviously
benefits to having income from
International students but we shouldn't
be overly Reliant upon it
so Desmond Swain when these measures
have their effect
surely we will then be able to treat
foreign students as the booming export
that they are rather than immigration
well foreign students education of
international students is an important
export industry I believe it's the
fourth or fifth biggest export industry
of the UK and that's a good thing and
something that is supported by the
government that's why we created the
International Education strategy that
has proven to be so successful but what
we're doing today is ensuring that we
don't see unintended consequences and
unnecessary pressure on public service
as a result
so what impact will these changes have
on the number of students from overseas
coming to study in British universities
and what will be the financial
consequences of these changes has the
home office made that assessment
uh well as I said in answer to an
earlier question we have already met our
Target of 600 000 students coming to the
UK from overseas that's 10 years early
last year in fact there were 605 000. we
expect the numbers to increase this year
Beyond 600
000 and so there's no suggestion that
universities are going to be
shortchanged as a result of this but in
the medium term it will obviously
involve fewer dependents coming with
those International students and for the
reasons I've already set out we think
that's a good thing perhaps he doesn't
incredibly
this measure is Holy to be welcomed but
the fact is that legal migration is out
of control
and the British people didn't vote for
brexit to replace Mass migration from
Europe with mass migration for the rest
of the world so can I press
can I press the minister on this point
made by my honorable friend we're never
going to deal with legal migration until
we solve this labor problem that
homegrown Employers in Britain are
paying two low wages and they're trying
to attract people from all over the
world so why don't we raise the
threshold to the average earnings you
have to earn average earnings if you
want to come here and get a job
well I'm grateful to my original friend
for his support he's right that having
left the European Union taken back
control of our borders and migration
policy it's absolutely critical that we
make good on our promise to bring net
migration down because it does put an
intolerable pressure on public services
on housing it does strain Community
cohesion particularly when it happens at
a scale and speed uh which is too great
for many people in uh the Britain
British Society he makes an important
point about the workings of the
points-based system and the salary
thresholds for the shortage occupation
list and for General work visas and that
is something that the government keeps
under review because we don't want to
see employers reaching for international
labor rather than seeking to recruit and
train domestic labor reducing
unemployment reducing people who are on
benefits Samsung
thank you very much Mr Speaker the Home
Secretary makes contradictory statements
to different audiences and thinks that
nobody has noticed her slight of hand
she recommitted yesterday to bringing in
600 000 International students per year
but as the minister now regret that
after having completely lost control of
immigration figures she actually
expressed her desire to reduce student
visas at last year's Conservative Party
Conference
well the Home Secretary and I are
completely at one in our determination
to reduce net migration that is what
this party stood on a Manifesto to do
and that's what we intend to achieve the
home sector and I want to find ways in
which we can tackle abuse and unintended
consequences within the system and the
package of measures we set out this week
will do so in a very important and as
his own party appears now to support it
clearly significant and cross-party area
so John pays thank you Mr Speaker I
refer the house to my entry in the
register of Interest as the minister
considers work visas which have exploded
and displaced investment and domestic
skills and displace uh the kind of
investment in modernity and working
practices that are fit for the future
will you also answer this question
why is it right and fair for those
students studying a research degree
to allow to let to be able to bring
their people into the country but not
fair for people who are not doing
primary research surely if those
studying for Mas that don't require
research can't bring their family no one
should be able to
uh well we've said in the announcement
this week that we with the department
for Education will launch a consultation
with the university sector to design a
longer term alternative to uh what the
system that previously operated which
could be a more nuanced approach but I
think the the determination we've made
this week is the right one that those
people coming into the UK to study will
only be able to bring dependents in if
they are doing those high value
usually longer term research-based
courses such as phds and those coming
for short courses uh will invariably not
be able to do so that will cut out some
of the abuse that we've seen in the
system today and will focus universities
on their primary responsibility which is
teaching an education rather than in
some cases being a back door to
immigration and to work
Peter Grant
Mr Speaker later this afternoon my much
valued international student Jacqueline
will spend the last few years of a time
here before she completes her internship
Jacqueline has been a massive massive
asset to my office after us have the
other Lac and other interns offered the
privilege of working with over the last
number of years
what should I say to Jacqueline should I
say thank you you have been a boon to
this place and to these islands should I
say to her you're a problem that has to
be controlled
well it'll be helpful if the honor
General didn't spread this information
to uh his uh his researcher or indeed to
anyone else it was the government who
created through the International
Education strategy this commitment that
has proven to be so successful that has
led to 600 000 International students
coming to the UK perhaps including uh
the lady he refers to we also created
the gradual route which has enabled
people potentially including uh his
researcher to move seamlessly into the
workplace here in the UK after their
studies rather than having to
immediately apply for a work or family
Visa as used to happen in the past so
there's no suggestion that there's any
diminution in our support for
universities or in International
students but it is right that we get a
grip on abuses or unintended
consequences that's what governments
have to do when you're trying to control
an immigration system maybe he doesn't
want controlled immigration we do that's
why we have to take these steps Aaron
Bell thank you Mr Speaker International
students studying high quality courses
at high quality universities like Keel
in my constituency which I know the
minister knows well add a huge amount to
our local economy but isn't it
absolutely clear from the figures he
quoted earlier about the increased
independent visas that some universities
have wittingly or otherwise been selling
immigration rather than education and
isn't it vital that we get on top of
this
[Music]
I completely agree with the honorable
gentleman universities such as Kiel I I
I know that University well have played
a critical role in the economic
development of local communities and we
want to encourage that but it it is
important that universities primarily
focus on education not creating courses
which are then marketed overseas to
individuals whose primary interest is in
coming to the UK for immigration and
work purposes and for the courses being
a back door to them that bloodshot
isn't the truth that Mr Speaker that
excellent universities like mine and
Exeter have sought since brexit to
replace those thousands of EU students
they've lost with students from other
parts of the world who tend for cultural
and other reasons to bring more family
members spouses and children with them
so isn't the government having to clear
up another brexit mess of its own making
and will he be honest with the house and
explain how he's going to avoid
discriminating against countries like
Nigeria and India where students do tend
to bring dependents and make us even
more reliant on students from China
well it's a curious argument that he's
making because of course it was as a
result of leaving the European Union
that we've created an entirely
non-discriminatory immigration system
that has enabled people to apply to come
to the UK whether for work purposes or
indeed a student from anywhere in the
world rather than making it more
difficult for those from outside the EU
and having a very large number of EU
citizens come here the proposals we're
bringing place today will tackle this
particular unintended consequence of the
opening up of international students I
don't see any evidence that it will harm
particular nationalities there are some
glaring examples like like the Nigerian
one I mentioned uh previously but this
will apply to everyone it's entirely
non-discriminatory policy it should even
happen
speaker my right honorable friend is
completely right that we must choose who
comes here we must strike out of use
Wimbledon has many English language
schools and English language is a key
part of the International Education
strategy given the specific and
short-term nature of these students
given they bring in no Independence and
given also that there are another costs
on our Public Services would he meet me
and the leaders of the sector to discuss
this uh restoring work visas for these
specific group of students
uh well be pleased to meet with my
honorable friend and to discuss that and
uh as I said earlier with respect to the
announce we've made today we will be
doing a consultation with the department
for Education that will give
universities the opportunity to set out
their case and refine the policy if it's
necessary he does highlight one of the
other elements of the announcement that
we've made this week which is clamping
down on abuse there are a small number
of unscrupulous education agents who may
be supporting disingenuous applications
which are selling immigration rather
than education and one of the measures
we're taking this week is to clamp down
on those much more targeted and
effective enforcement activity
speaker my Edinburgh South West
constituents do not share the Tory and
labor obsession with net migration they
understand that Scotland benefits from
inward migration and in fact the
university UK research shows that my
constituency is net economic benefit
from International students is
170.8 million pounds which gives the lie
to most of what the minister has said
now continuing as a member of the United
Kingdom is damaging Scotland's
universities including Edinburgh Naper
Napier and Harriet watt in my
constituency first brexit now this the
union has to work for both Partners so
why won't the minister sit down with the
Home Secretary and consider devolving
immigration policies relating to student
visas to the Scottish Parliament yeah
yeah well as I've said many times before
with no intention of devolving
immigration policy and on the broader
questions there's no material difference
between Scotland and the rest of the
United Kingdom in terms of unemployment
or economic inactivity and so there's no
compelling case for a bespoke
immigration system for Scotland versus
the rest of the United Kingdom and the
sheer scale of the number of
international students that have come
into the UK all parts including to
Scotland in recent years suggests that
the policies of this government have
increased the number of international
students not diminished them
victim
Mr Speaker pressures in migration policy
ultimately lead back to the efficient
processing of everyone who UK VI has to
deal with can my right and refund assure
me that this change will help UK VI make
more decisions more quickly yeah well
I'm pleased to say that UK VI today is a
very well-run organization and uh the
superb leadership of an official in the
home office called Mark Owen and that in
every one of the Visa categories it is
meeting its service standard or
significantly exceeding them and so I
know the lady always likes to deal in
anecdote rather than statistics but I'm
afraid to disappoint her it is
speaker I for one am very proud of the
international students in my community
Oxford Brooks and of course Oxford
University they Pride themselves on
being able to attract the best and
brightest and this policy is going to
make that harder and we value them
because they bring value they bring on
average value of 400 million pounds to
the Oxfordshire economy so why is this
government and apparently also the labor
party intent on stifling our
universities but also our economy
I have a question for The Honorable lady
but she is probably the greatest NIMBY
in the House of Commons today she always
opposes new homes new development new
infrastructure in and around Oxford and
so he's quite wrong for her to say that
we should have an open door immigration
policy welcoming more and more people
into her community and others without
meeting the demands that come with that
in terms of Housing and infrastructure
I am uncomfortable with net migration
being at the levels it currently is and
as I do I believe in most of my
constituents I I understand what the
government doing about one year taught
Mars since they seem to be about 95
absolutely makes sense however I do have
some concerns that some universities
might try and gain the system and
re-label one year talk marches one year
research Masters I understand why phds
are treated differently but we're
Minister assured me that this will not
happen we'll clamp down on that and but
he also come in upon the two-year period
I believe that students get after they
graduate where they can stay here even
if they don't necessarily have a job
uh well we do believe that the changes
we're setting out today will make a a
marked uh impact on net migration we
will obviously monitor them very closely
for some of the unintended consequences
that that he refers to
um and the consultation that we will do
with universities in the broader sector
will help us to refine the policy should
it be necessary going forward
stupid kid
ministers already acknowledge that the
vast majority of students return home in
fact the compliance rate for
international student visas is 97.5
the highest for any UK Visa category
doesn't that suggest there may be better
targets for the government's Energies
well there's no one single intervention
that will solve this challenge but this
isn't what it is I think a significant
intervention that will make a material
difference to net migration he's right
to say that the overwhelming majority of
students historically International
students historically have left at the
end of their studies or shortly
thereafter it is possible that the
system that has evolved since 2019 will
see different Trends because in 2020
only 7 400 non-eu students stayed on
post-study those numbers will be
dramatically higher in the years ahead
and so it may be that the mix of
individuals the countries that they come
from the fact that they're bringing
dependents with them in many cases will
lead to far higher number of individuals
staying on post-study but I don't think
we'll see those Trends clearly enough
this year we may see them in the years
to come
Mr Speaker many of my constituents
continue to be deeply concerned about
the levels of net migration not just
over the last few years but the last few
decades and they along with myself will
welcome the measures outlined by the
minister today is he able to update the
house on any measures his department has
taken to tackle bogus College placements
from students who sometimes come to this
country only to disappear Into Thin Air
well alongside the package of measures
uh today uh I as I said earlier we are
taking further targeted enforcement
activity against unscrupulous education
agents who are selling immigration entry
to the United Kingdom rather than
education we're also going to work
closely with universities in the
department for education to improve
communication to universities and their
Affiliates of immigration rules so that
we can clamp down on the kinds of poor
practices that he described
speaker the minister avoided this
question
honorable friend asked it so I'll try
again what discussions were there
between the UK government and Scottish
ministers on this matter before the
announcement was made
uh well immigration is a reserved matter
um but I I I I would just add that I am
seeking a meeting with the relevant
cabinet secretary in the Scottish
government to discuss illegal migration
but her office has so far not offered a
meeting
Liberate the huge growth in
international student numbers I assume
that's the education department and the
treasury insisted should go in
um but within that there is a welcome
diversification in that growth away from
over-dependence on China
and that was a deliberate part of the
International Education strategy now
the minister talks about unintended
consequences but it was entirely
predictable that those coming from other
countries for Masters courses would come
from a different demographic than
Chinese students that they would have
families and that like us they wouldn't
want to be separated from them yeah
that's right now our competitors welcome
students with families so there is a
real risk that a blanket ban on
dependence will undermine the
government's own International Education
strategy now the statement
commits to Consulting with universities
in developing the approach
so will he confirm that there'll be no
blanket ban on dependence of PGT
students until that consultation has
taken place
well we will implement the policy that
we set out yesterday but concurrently
with that we will launch the
consultation with universities and if we
need to refine the policy in the future
as a result of that we will do so to his
first point I don't think there's any
reason why a Chinese student would be
less likely to bring dependents with
them to United Kingdom than a Nigerian
or a Vietnamese or a Bangladeshi uh
there's I don't I don't follow his logic
there at all we want an entirely
non-discriminatory approach and that is
what we have said to our International
counterparts this week that's always
been our approach to this we welcome
International students from any part of
the world
okay thank you Mr Speaker the vast
majority of these students access their
courses in the north of England through
Manchester Airport in my constituency
would the minister agree to an economic
impact assessment on how this will
impact jobs in my constituency and Route
development and the cost of that to The
Wider northern economy
well I was pleased to be at Manchester
Airport only on Friday meeting with my
board Force officials there and seeing
the expansion of the airport that's
currently underway
um I don't foresee any serious uh loss
of revenue for an airport like
Manchester the number of individuals
coming into the UK as International
students has risen very significantly in
recent years so to the extent that
provides income to airports they will
have benefited from our existing policy
and I expect them to benefit in the
future running fellows
foreign
question even it only is to expose that
you couldn't put a cigarette paper
between labor and Tory policies on this
Scotland has a track record and
welcoming International students
and and to our internationally
recognized universities Scotland wants
and needs the benefits they bring
this government's continuous refusal to
devolve immigration powers to the
Scottish government shows the contempt
that this government has for Scotland
why doesn't this government understand
and recognize that things are different
there and continual refusal to do what
Scotland needs and wants is going to
come down heavy on them in the next
election
well at the risk of repeating myself
there's no material difference between
unemployment or economic inactivity in
Scotland and the rest of the United
Kingdom so The Honorable lady is
incorrect in that regard and the UK
benefits enormously from having a single
immigration policy an offer to
International students and universities
in all parts of the world Stephen Curry
in Northern Ireland our local
universities are very dependent upon
International students particularly so
in light of the current budget crisis
that we are we are facing also employers
are reflecting they can't access labor
without that migration and indeed which
I'm sure is the same for the rest of the
UK our public services that actually
depend upon migrants for their basic
functioning rather than being a burden
so why is the government so insistent
and acting against core interests of our
public services our economy and our
local universities
it could be further from the truth
because of course it's this government
that established the International
Education strategy that's led to uh 600
000 International students coming to the
UK every year
um and indeed that number is likely to
grow next year with respect to Public
Services we created the Health and
Social care Visa which last year led to
000 applications uh plus of course their
dependents are able to join them and
that was 11 of all of the Visas issued
to individuals wishing to come to the
United Kingdom so we're doing everything
we can to support public services but we
have to address the fact that very high
levels of net migration do Place
intolerable pressure on housing on
public services and on integration
and here Wilson thank you Mr Speaker our
schools are in the midst of such a
chronic recruitment teacher Recruitment
and Retention crisis that the department
for Education currently offers ten
thousand pound relocation payments to
overseas applicants to come and train as
language and physics teachers in the UK
on postgraduate taught courses if they
can't bring their family they won't want
to settle here and use the training that
we've provided in our schools where
they're desperately needed why is the
government cutting off its nose despite
its own face
well if the honorable lady is referring
to pressure on school place is that
would be a good argument for reducing
the number of dependents coming into the
United Kingdom because it's exactly the
children of students who in some cases
will be making use of primary schools in
her constituency Jeff Smith uh thank you
Mr Speaker the minister still hasn't
said what economic impact assessment the
government has carried out of this
policy will he publish one
yeah
um well I've said already that we take a
pragmatic approach to this issue we are
balancing our strong desire to bring
down net migration with the needs of the
economy that's why we've taken the
approach of standing behind the 600 000
Target for international students but
making this important tweak to ensure
doesn't abuse I think red
of course net migration figures also
include the number
and his hard brexit has made it more
difficult for students on others to
travel overseas so that's having an
impact on the migration figures as well
meanwhile Glasgow North thrives
culturally and socially and economically
to the tune of 225.8 million thanks to
our Lively and diverse international
student Community but what I'd really
like to know is why does the scdo spend
millions of pounds on overseas campaigns
that says Britain is great when the
message coming from the home office is
that Britain is closed
well I do wonder what world uh The
Honorable gentleman lives on if he
thinks that net migration of half a
million is low that's too little that we
should be encouraging more the levels of
net migration to this country are very
high today we want to bring those down
and it's for that reason we're taking
measures like this
the University of Cumbria and Lancaster
University are a hugely successful
institutions we're very proud of them
they're really important to our economy
and indeed they are very successful
exporters what is their export high
quality education delivered in the
United Kingdom so why is the government
seeking to stifle our great exporters
ability to export why they become
suddenly anti-free market and what they
recognize well the minister recognize
that by earning money through
International students British
universities are able to cross-subsidize
services and places for British students
well British students be the people who
paid the price well as I said an answer
to an earlier question the economic
benefit of international students is
clear and we welcome uh that but we
don't want British universities to
become totally reliant on income from
International students just a few years
ago that was accounted for five percent
of their income last year it was 18 and
without measures like this no doubt it
would continue to rise to to his broader
point of course we want to support
universities like his own to thrive and
to prosper and to Market themselves
internationally but the business of
universities education not immigration
this presentation
can I thank the minister for the the
answers to the questions and I do
welcome the announcement that it does
show considerable effort in committing
to the government's pledge to crack down
on that migration however what
assessment has the minister made on the
the number of children that will
ultimately be left behind whilst their
parents come to the UK to study for a
better life but cannot bring their
little ones with them on their journey
to study and to crucially maintain
Family Life which I feel is really
important
well that's one of the considerations
why we have said that those coming here
for longer term research courses such as
phds can continue to bring their
dependents with them because absolutely
a form was coming to the UK for a
sustained period of time it would be
right for them to to relocate in a more
substantial way but if individuals are
making a choice to come here say for a
one-year Master's course then I think
it's perfectly appropriate for the UK to
say that that's their decision and they
shouldn't bring their dependence with
them for that course
we now come to the statement
minister